I got this tattoo a couple years ago
maybe two years it's not the best tattoo
cuz for example if you roll up if I roll
up my sleeve kind of looks like two
balls hanging out you may be familiar
with it already it's a it's a figurine
made by cause which used to sell for
like 50 bucks but I think now they're
like 2 grand if you're lucky enough to
find one cuz cause has gotten so popular
that was really worried when I got it
cuz I thought maybe even too popular and
yeah in some ways I was right I cringe
every time another reason you might
recognize it previously is because um
the figurine is a variation of Astro Boy
which is 50s 60s Japanese superhero and
if you're such a Strobel on youtube
you'll find a picture typically where
he's fist towards the sky with a smile
um
striking that superhero pose but in this
variation as her boys lean forward
he's covering his face in shame and we
see Astro Boy in a way that typically
would never happen at least in the
original manga and and I think when
you're a character that people look up
to it's not typical to show certain
types of emotions for me seeing Astro
Boy in a way that's so unlike the
typical way that people usually perceive
him I know it's a little cheesy made me
think it's okay to not always be the way
you're typically seen by people s
although we might never actually see it
everyone gets down everyone in a while
everyone feels the way as good ol Astro
Boy feels no matter who you are although
we might not actually ever see it
everyone gets down from time to time
even if you're a superhero like Astro
Boy
that's my favorite tattoo I'm back and I
feel so much better to be back already
if you don't know I took some time off
to work on scare PewDiePie season 2 the
show my my own show it should be coming
out early next year it was so much more
intense way more than I ever expected
this this season really steps it up so
much and I feel really confident that
you guys you bros anyone really will
really enjoy watching it cuz we had such
a blast filming it and I think each
episode on this one is really strong I'm
probably not supposed to say this but
jacksepticeye is sort of a villain of
the show and he flew in the last couple
days to shoot some trailer stuff with me
we got to do some kung-fu moves and got
to ride a motorcycle and it's just
awesome it was so much fun I worked
every single day that week but it was
totally worth it and in the finale we
kind of went head to head in the end we
were both kind of up on this stage in
front of everyone that worked on the
show and it was just a really really
awesome moment so memorable for me I
don't want to spoil anything but I was
just really happy Jack was there and it
was cool to share that moment with him
I'm so excited for you guys to watch his
season I want to say a huge thanks to
everyone who worked on the production
they obviously work ten times harder
than I did and I just really appreciate
all the hard work that went into it so
everyone that worked on it you know you
are thank you all the guests that came
and went on the show everyone was so
good we didn't have a single bad guest
some even flew over to LA just to be
part of the show which I really really
appreciate and
[Music]
just thank you thanks again to Brad and
Michael for flying over with me and
being part of me while I did this they
were a huge help and I really appreciate
their support
same with Marzia of course for
supporting me these three weeks and
being by my side she obviously took time
off her what she was doing to be with me
and and I really appreciate that but
also thanks to you on my last video all
the support was just incredible and it
means a lot that you were all there for
me when I needed it and every one that
contacted me and wrote me to make sure I
was okay I'm really fine I really have I
really have the best life ever
I have no reason to complain or Oh
boohoo I'm stressed but I think it's
normal to get down every once in a while
I'm just so happy to be back I'm excited
to make videos again and I'll be back
tomorrow with another one Edgar hey guy
come here finally black with Edgar I
missed your porch I missed you I've
yours gotten fat now the one that took
care of him clearly fed him too much I
don't think Edgar has any objections to
that so I am don't mean to keep saying
thank you but thanks for your support
thanks for waiting for me when I'm gone
I really appreciate that I have an
audience that support what I do in a way
that is more than just videos almost
that makes sense really kept me going
throughout these days and I appreciate
you so as always we're gonna end it with
a professed thanks for leaving a like I
guess I gotta beg for that now that
YouTube changed the system and I'll see
you bros in the next video stay awesome
brush
I almost how could I forget I haven't
met met sleepy in three weeks hope is
alive oh maybe Oh
how you doing buddy I missed you don't
[ __ ] how you doing my little
cheeseburger oh are you gonna [ __ ] are
you pissed that I always gonna [ __ ]
probably pissed I'm sorry hey sleepy I'm
sorry good his legs
well I missed you too sleepy never
change mom man it's a sign of affection
when they [ __ ]
it means they love you right
[Music]